[INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Product management,
and I lead up our mobile
display ads teams.
We thought that we would
spend some time today
talking with all of
you about what we're
seeing in the mobile app space
in terms of monetization;
how people are building not
just small businesses, but truly
global businesses on the backs
of mobile apps; the trends
that we're seeing, the
techniques that people are
using, and importantly,
some of the tools
that we're building to make
this easier for all of you.
We're going to look at this
in three specific areas--
first, this concept of
smarter monetization.
How you can take advantage
of data and tools
that exist today, both
manual and automatic,
to build really
innovative business models
on the backs of mobile apps.
Second, the tools that you
need to scale your businesses.
Many app developers
start with a couple
of folks in their garage,
and before they know it,
they've created a
multimillion dollar business.
You want to make sure that
the tools that you adopt
into your app are
tools that will
help you to scale
from small businesses
to multi-billion dollar ones.
And three, simplicity.
Because most importantly,
you guys are app developers.
You want to spend your time
thinking about the apps
that you're building, making
those better, creating really
rich, engaging experiences--
and the last thing
that you want to worry about
is letting monetization,
or business models,
get in the way.
Now, I've had an
incredible opportunity
working with AdMob, my
team, and my partners
for the better part of the
last three or four years.
And without a doubt, one of
the best experiences that I get
is to travel this
wonderful globe
and to meet app developers
in all regions of the world.
I get to meet app
developers right here
in my hometown of
San Francisco, I
get to meet amazing
developers in places
like Japan and Tokyo
and London, as well
as in places like Vietnam.
And it's stunning, because
these stories are the same over
and over again-- you find
bright, young entrepreneurial
folks who know that
they can change
the world with some software
on a mobile application.
And we understand
that the barriers
of the world, these
country borders
are fading away, as people in
the furthest reaches of Earth
are building businesses
that are touching us
all around the world.
So we thought we would
start with just two examples
to give you a feel for how
folks are turning mobile apps
into truly global businesses.
The first is a story
of our friend Mehmet.
He's the co-founder
and CEO of Gram Games.
Mehmet grew up in Turkey
in a small village
called [? Golnar. ?] He
dropped out of college,
but he always had a
passion for engineering,
for software development,
and for coding.
And so he taught
himself to program.
Mehmet was a little
bit ambitious,
and within three
weeks he was trying
to figure out how to
write AI for chess games.
He worked for a variety
of different companies
as a developer, but he had this
itch for his passion, which
was gaming.
And so he co-founded a
company, Gram Games, in 2012.
Wasn't easy at first.
You can see how they
operated when they first
got started-- about
five of them working out
of their apartments, as
you kind of have to do.
And they were working really
hard to try to develop a hit.
They kept building app
after app after app,
but nothing was sticking.
And then all of a
sudden, in 2014,
the winds changed for them.
And they developed
a truly massive hit.
I hope some of you of
you in the audience--
raise your hand, come on,
who's played 10 10 Puzzle?
I certainly have.
Yeah, see, there we go.
And you see how quickly
the stuff spreads.
Before long, they had 5 million
users playing this game.
And they realized, now
we have an opportunity
to build a business.
So they employed
in-app purchases,
trying to get users to pay
to play more of the game
that they loved.
But with 5 million users, and
with not a high percentage
of users willing
to pay, they really
struggled to create a business
off of in-app purchase.
Late in 2014, they started
researching mobile app
advertising systems, and
they came upon AdMob.
Mehmet liked AdMob
because it had a high fill
rate, strong CPMs,
which meant it
was going to deliver him revenue
without a lot of complexity.
So in the back half of 2014,
they implemented AdMob.
And before they knew it, they
were generating $5,000 a day
in earnings-- which grew
their business seven-fold.
They utilized mobile ads
in a fairly simple way,
leveraging banner
ads for in-game play,
and then interstitials
in between the levels.
And thanks to AdMob,
they were able to move
from their apartment
to new offices.
They grew from five
employees to 20,
and they've now
scaled-- they have
20 million users worldwide.
And see an example up there,
you can see their team behind me
here, you can see
their new offices.
And they're one of
the fastest growing
startups in all of Turkey.
And the thing that
really impresses
me is that they have such
a passion about this space,
that they now run
their own accelerator
program to help other indie game
developers get off the ground.
Our next example comes
from Backflip Studios.
Julian is the co-founder
and CEO there,
and they have one of the oldest
and most favorite of mobile app
games.
We're going to show you an
example of that right now.
Can you play the video?
JULIAN FARRIOR: I feel
like I'm living out
my 12-year-old dream,
which is to have created
an interesting gaming company.
And we get to create product
that people care about,
and that resonates from
an emotional standpoint
with a very broad
range of folks.
Backflip Studios started
about six years ago
with a small group of people,
and we went to market quickly.
We started it with
the idea that mobile
was going to change
the landscape
and ecosystem of gaming.
So we created all these
free, engaging, casual games.
And we had this huge
audience, but at the time,
we weren't really sure how
we were going to monetize it,
and how we were going to create
a sustainable gaming company
out of that.
KEVIN KING: When you're
creating a mobile business,
you have to focus
on the stability,
and you have to be able
to scale that operation.
Without Google, we
would have to work
with about 20 different partners
to be able to accomplish
what we do today.
JULIAN FARRIOR: We use the
Android platform, in addition
to App Engine.
And we've really seen
our live products
be able to scale with
the server infrastructure
and back-end infrastructure
of App Engine.
JASON DALRYMPLE:
We then monetize
those games with in-app
purchases, virtual goods,
as well as advertising.
And we use DFP to run
our internal ad network,
and then we monetize
using AdMob.
KEVIN KING: In
order to do that, we
have to acquire users
at a very low cost,
and at a very large scale.
JASON DALRYMPLE: So we know
that 90% to 95% of our users
are not going to
spend within the game.
Google allows us to
segment our users in order
to maximize the value we can
get from folks who are spending
in the game, as well as
advertising revenue for folks
who are not spending
in the game.
On the engaged side, we
have Google Cloud Storage
to scale our game as it grows.
We post our game in
the Google Play Store.
KEVIN KING: Being able
to target users based off
of demographics, spend
behavior, makes it
so we have a better
relationship with the customers
we're trying to reach.
And AdWords is
the first platform
that we have used that
allows us to target directly
customers who are guaranteed
to have made a purchase.
JULIAN FARRIOR: The
idea that Google
has a number of different
tools that we can leverage,
it's allowed us to manage a
portfolio of varying products
with different revenue
models on each.
JASON DALRYMPLE:
Google's product roadmap
is really impressive, and
it's become the Swiss army
knife for us in terms
of monetization,
and we're excited to see
what else they're going
to come out with.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
My team and I
thought that that was a
fantastic summary of how Google
is really pulling together all
of the assets, all of the tools
that we've been providing to
app developers for the better
part of the last
five years or so,
and really getting
them stitched together
under a single umbrella, so
that app developers know that we
truly provide a full
suite-- from development
through monetization, to things
like cloud storage, compute, et
cetera.
So we know that
lots of developers,
like the two that
we've seen here today,
are taking advantage
of Google solutions
to help them grow
their businesses.
Our solutions, and the
solutions that we're building,
we hope to empower all of you
to grow app businesses just
as quickly, just a
scaled around the world.
We talk about
scale-- I think it's
absolutely important to
understand that yes, we're
Google.
And yes, this is a
Google I/O conference.
But we're here to
serve app developers,
regardless of the platform
that they choose to operate on.
AdMob has been committed
to cross platform
on both iOS and Android long
before Google purchased AdMob.
This was the case, and it
continues through to today.
Over the last 12 months,
we have seen equal growth
on the iOS and Android
platforms in terms
of the number of developers
that are adopting our products.
And if you want to
hear about scale,
we've grown to a very
significant scale
in terms of the number
of apps that we now
serve-- over 650,000-- and
in terms of the ad requests
that we see every month.
That number is now 200
billion ad requests a month.
And you think a little
bit about this--
we are seeing the
growth of the mobile ads
ecosystem, the mobile ads in-app
ecosystem at Google directly.
But that is growth
that we expect,
and folks outside
of Google expect,
to continue for the
foreseeable future at least.
In fact, the predictions
suggest that mobile, in-app ads
are set to grow three-fold in
roughly the next three years.
And important to understand--
because I know many folks
think that mobile
ads in apps make up
a small slice of
the revenue, most
coming from in-app purchase--
that is no longer the case.
And you'll see why in a second.
But in many of
the major markets,
mobile ads now represent 50% or
more of the total app revenue
that our app
developers are earning.
So I think the question
is, what's driving this?
What's driving this continued
increase in mobile ads?
And if we look at it, we
believe that there's really
three distinct trends.
First, as always, is users.
And users vote with their
clicks, as they're doing here.
90% of all apps that are
downloaded today are free.
And you can see the
phenomenal growth-- there
it is-- you can see the
phenomenal growth that we've
had in app downloads
over the years,
and projections moving forward.
But also recognize that that
little, darker bar at the top,
that's it for the paid apps.
More and more users know that
they can download and engage
and play truly
phenomenal apps for free,
and they're voting
with their finger.
So that's trend number one.
Trend number two, in-app
purchase works, it
works great for those that
know how to really optimize
and tune it, it's
absolutely phenomenal.
But dammit, you better do
a good job of turning it,
because only 1.5% of users, of
mobile gamers, spend in apps.
So you've got to find
that right audience
if in-app purchase is the only
way you're going to monetize.
And even more complicated,
in-app purchase tendencies
vary a lot per region.
So while that business
model might do well for you
in Korea or Japan,
for example, you
might struggle as users
don't end up paying
as much in the US or the UK.
The third trend
that we really think
is transforming mobile ads
is much, much better user
experiences.
We highlight three here.
The first is native advertising.
So because we're bringing ads
into these experiences that
feel like the experiences
that users are in,
it's much less
jarring, and I think
the word native is perfect.
This is the way folks see it.
They see it as native to the
environment that they're in.
The second is that
we're starting
to see the transformation
that we've been expecting,
with rich media
ads, full screen,
interstitial-- we call them
light box ads at Google--
the uptake here has
been very significant.
These are much easier to
create than in years past.
They provide rich interaction.
They allow users to actually
interact with the products
that they're
considering purchasing.
And the last has
been video-- video
has transformed mobile overall,
and the advertising space
is no exception.
So publishers are able
to earn a lot more money
with these types of formats.
And with Google, you can
leverage TrueView ads,
which put the user in control.
So the user has the choice
to skip the ad if it's not
relevant to her desires.
Ultimately, all of
this momentum is
leading to a very, very
significant market.
Most projections estimate the
mobile app advertising market
to be north of $50 billion.
This suggests $60
billion by 2017.
$60 billion is an
awful lot of money,
and it's one of the
things in at least
my experiences that is pushing
more and more folks to want
to become app developers.
You want your own opportunity
to get a slice of this pie.
But you're going to
have to think carefully,
because the competition
is increasing,
and the business models
are getting more complex.
And if you just choose
simple business models,
like in-app purchase
or advertising,
chances are you're
going to come up short,
and you're not going
to be able to compete
against some of the other
folks who are out there.
And we believe that
until now, developers
have not had the right
tools to really embrace
the opportunity that's out there
to create these new business
models.
And that's what we've
been so hard at work
at Google at an AdMob building
for the last 18 months or so.
Solving monetization
on apps is a passion
that doesn't just
consume me, but consumes
my team on a daily basis.
That's why we're so excited
about some of the announcements
we have today.
So what should the
strategy be for your app?
How can you do it better?
And why is it important
to get it right now?
Well, the competition is
growing, as I mentioned.
In 2014 alone, one
million new apps
were created and
uploaded to the stores.
There's almost six million
developers now, worldwide,
with one and a half million
developers in North America
alone.
And this number will also grow.
As the democratization of
software development, coding
and distribution continues
to blanket the world,
we expect eight million
developers by the year 2017.
All of this means more
competition for all of you
as app developers-- for the
eyeballs, the mindshare,
and ultimately the
monetization of your users.
So we're here to give you some
tips, some thoughts that we
have about what's going
to help all of you
break out from the rest
of the competition.
Here's three.
First, we believe
you need to realize
the full value of each user.
Not all users will interact
with in-app purchases.
Not all are going to
interact with ads.
And that's what we're
demonstrating here.
We have a set of users
who are likely to spend
in in-app purchase, but
a separate set of users
who are likely to click on ads.
And a third set who
maybe aren't going
to engage with
either one of those,
but who will happily
spread the good word of how
well your app works,
or how awesome
your game is on social media.
You should probably-- and
the sophisticated developers
in the audience are nodding,
because you get it--
you should probably be dealing
with these users differently,
and be building hybridized
business models that
take all of them into account.
The second tip we'd
have-- and I've
been talking about this
for the last three years,
easily-- please, use a mobile
apps analytics package.
Google Analytics
works great, we're
going to talk more
about that in a second.
The Google Analytics team
has been really working
hard to build the best mobile
apps analytics package,
we'd love for you to use them.
But for you guys, and for
your own businesses' sake,
make sure you use some
analytics package.
Because even though
we've been out espousing
how important this
is, and when you
do you get the nods from
everybody you talk to,
look at this stat.
I'm sorry for the
language, but I
don't know what the hell the
other 79% of the app developers
are doing-- you're
not able to understand
what the hell's going
on inside your app.
But it's not sufficient
just to use analytics.
Mike Shipper, my good friend
who helps me with these slides,
he and I created
this visualization.
We love it because
we're of the age
that we grew up with Hobbit
and Lord of the Rings
and all that long
before the movies.
And if you remember
The Hobbit, you
remember Bilbo Baggins
and the cast of characters
climbing to the mountain,
to the Lonely Mountain,
because the dragon
Smaug had come in,
knocked out all the dwarves,
and sat perched on top
of the dwarves' treasure hold.
Mike and I thought this
was almost comical.
Like, what the hell
is a dragon going
to do with all of this gold?
It's the same thing
with the data.
You can't just have a
data analytics package
and let it sit there.
You are sitting on a veritable
treasure trove of information,
and we implore you to
take action on the data
that you've been acquiring.
The third suggestion we
have is to truly maximize
your ad yield.
You have so many opportunities
for monetization, so many
different avenues that you
can bring ads and different ad
formats in, make
sure you're looking
as holistically as possible,
use a yield management solution
if you have one, and make
sure that every impression is
maximized to the most possible.
What you see here-- we
just cut off the y-axis
so we wouldn't share
the actual CPM values--
but these are relative
CPMs on our network
of TrueView versus
interstitials versus banners.
So you might say, OK,
well I'm just going
to use TrueView all the time.
But that may not work
for all of your users,
and you may not get 100%
fill rate on TrueView.
So think about the other ad
formats that you can mix in,
as well.
Because ultimately,
different formats
will bring a richer
experience to your app,
and help you earn more.
Talking about interstitials,
specifically, we've
been out evangelizing how
great interstitials are--
from an advertiser perspective,
absolutely; from a publisher
perspective, because
you can earn more money;
and from a user perspective,
because believe it or not,
interstitials end up being
a little less disruptive.
Most app developers are able
to swap out about five banner
ads for a single interstitial.
And you're able to
more carefully place
those into the flow of the game,
simulating the kinds of things
that users are used to,
like TV commercials.
And when our app developers
make use of interstitials,
they don't use it all the time.
But those who do use some
interstitials see on average
20% more revenue than those
app developers who don't.
Speaking of demand, speaking
of different formats,
when you're thinking
about the networks
that your plugging into
your monetization tool--
this is something known
as mediation, typically--
but you can always plug
multiple third party ad networks
into just about any monetization
tool for apps, including AdMob.
These networks all
perform differently.
Mediation doesn't solve all
these problems automatically
for you-- we're going to
talk about the innovations
that we're bringing--
you need to keep
an eye on how these various
networks are performing.
Because Network A might do
better on Wednesdays in China,
but Network B might do
better on Tuesdays in the US.
And you want to make sure that
you're optimizing these ad
networks correctly, so
that you're maximizing
your yield on every impression.
So now I want to
go a little deeper.
I want to talk about
what we're working on
at AdMob, the
features and the tools
that we have built to
help you take advantage
of some of these tips and tricks
that we just talked about.
So as we said in the
beginning, the principles
that we're leveraging
here, and the principles
that we're focused
on, are the same
that we're driving into AdMob.
First is to build a
platform they truly
enables smart monetization.
Where AdMob itself is a bit
of an optimization engine,
with data and users
fed in and us trying
figure out the right
monetization opportunity
for the right user
at the right time.
Second, make sure that you're
employing tools to scale.
So what are we doing at
Google to really help
you scale your business
from a demand perspective?
And last, how can we make
this as easy as possible?
So as I said, AdMob, the
focus and the real theme
of AdMob for the
last three years
now has been an
audience-aware smart platform.
The simplest way
to think about this
is that AdMob can
take a set of inputs--
in this case it's monetization
opportunities-- it also
takes as a set of
inputs all of the data
that it's seen about all
of the users you have
and their behavior in-app.
And churning
through this engine,
we can either put the
power in your hands,
or we can do it
automatically, and we
can provide that right
monetization opportunity
to the right user
at the right time.
In this case, AdMob decided
a video ad would probably
monetize best.
Let's look at another example,
where we take advantage
of the IAP business model.
So we have this feature in AdMob
called In-app purchase house
ads.
And the idea here is, these
will help you promote your IAP
items to those users who are
actually going to purchase.
And generally, when
I talk to developers,
these users are precious.
And what I hear is,
whatever you do,
make sure that you
build the best ring
fence you can around
my purchasers--
don't ever show them an ad,
only show them in-app purchases.
Sure, for everybody else,
you can do whatever you want,
but please don't muck
with these purchasers.
So this is what AdMob does
automatically on your behalf.
We're able to figure
out who the buyers are.
You heard [? Sumnder ?]
on stage--
we have incredible computer
scientists, massive sets
of machines, of computers,
and some of the best machine
learning systems in the world.
We're employing these to help
us predict those users that we
believe are likely to be
purchasers, both aggregately
and inside your app.
And we can wall
those off for you,
and we can make sure that
those users that we think
are bound to purchase
in your app only see
your IAP promotions.
And for everybody else,
we're happy to help
you show them ads.
The right ads at
the right time that
are going to monetize
best for those users.
This is one of these
hybrid business models
that we've talked about.
You're no longer just doing
IAP, you're no longer just doing
ads, but now you're doing a
hybrid of the two of them.
And when we started
running trials
with some of our partners
earlier this year,
the results that we saw
were quite stunning.
This is an example that's
going to walk you through one
of those sets of results.
This is with LunaSoft, who
is a developer down in Korea.
Now, these numbers
aren't the exact numbers,
but they were benchmarked
against those numbers
to represent the
uplift that we saw.
In the initial experiment,
they ran for six days,
and they just used their
traditional IAP business model.
They showed 145,000 impressions
to all of their users.
But remember, only a
small slice of those users
will actually engage
with these purchases.
So what that means is that your
monetization rate in aggregate
isn't that good, but they still
netted with the slightly north
of $100.
Their second
go-through here, they
took advantage of our
[? IP ?] house ads product.
And what they saw is that we
winnowed down those IAP offer
walls to the 6,000 users
that we expected to purchase.
And as a result, they made just
about $24 CPM on those users.
And that's cool, but that's
roughly the same rate
that they made in
the first case.
What excites me, my team, and
everybody I talk to about this,
is we have now freed up
139,000 impressions for folks
who weren't going to
engage in the first place,
and we can do all kinds
of other great things
with this, like show them ads.
And that's what LunaSoft did.
And as a result, they
made even more money
from these hybridized
business models,
while still protecting
those in-app purchase users.
Analytics has been the
key to really enabling
these kinds of use cases.
And this is why AdMob and Google
Analytics have been partnered
at the hip for the better
part, oh I don't know,
Russ-- the last two
and half, three years.
It's one of things
that I'm proudest of,
is this really strong,
tight connection
that these two teams have built.
And anybody out there
who's using AdMob
should understand
that underneath AdMob
is the full fledged version of
Google App Analytics-- it's not
just like a thin shim.
You really get this package with
both of them fully integrated.
Which enables things like
custom audience targeting.
Because once you have app
data flowing through AdMob,
we can open up a whole
slew of new opportunities.
You can take action on your own
data based on your own insights
and the things that you know.
And this begins with
a new tool that we
call audience builder,
which enables you to segment
users based on their behavior.
For example, the one
that I have behind me
segments between
those casual users,
and those highly engaged users.
Because often, we see
that app developers
want to do different things for
these different types of users.
Another great
example that I hear
is for users who are
brand new to an app,
maybe for the first
week or two weeks, let's
cut back on monetization,
we can ratchet it up
a little bit after they've
gotten fully engaged
in the game.
All of these things
are the kinds
of things that are possible
with Audience Builder.
Play the video here
for me, if you would.
And this is walking
you through a demo
of how this works inside AdMob.
So you're going to see
that we select our app,
we've already
segmented our audience,
and now we can target what to
do with those two segments.
So your casual, non-purchaser
is seeing ads at the top,
and your more engaged
user in a second
will see an in-app purchase
in just a few minutes.
All of this is
automatic, all of this
can happen thanks to the
data that you're pulling in,
the segmentations
that you're using,
and truly the opportunities
here are unlimited.
We're really excited to see
what you guys are going to do
with these tools in your hand.
So showing the right
ad at the right time
is an important part of running
one of these smart businesses.
And I mentioned
mediation earlier,
I want to talk a little
bit more about that now.
We've really invested
in our mediation product
over the last year,
because we know
that it is absolutely
critical to you that,
regardless of where you're
based and where your users are,
that you can get the best ads
and the best demand possible.
So today we mediate lots
of different types of ads
from banners to videos
to interstitials,
and we're working hard to
bring rewards-based mediation
to the AdMob platform in
the back half of this year.
Over the last year, we've
introduced 15 more networks
to the AdMob mediation
product, bringing us now
to 40 networks overall in 2015.
And you saw this at I/O-- our
most recent and most exciting
announcement is bringing
Tencent's Network, Tencent GDT,
to the AdMob platform, to
help all of our partners
in China monetize even better.
So I want to talk a little
bit more about mediation.
And I think most of you
know that mediation is not
the world's most
optimal ad product.
Ultimately, moving to a
single auction, things
like advertising exchanges
and real-time bidding,
have actually pooled
all of this demand
together to run
a single auction.
That's not how mediation works.
Mediation actually brings me
back to something like 1997,
with all of these callbacks.
We're going to try
ad network one.
If that doesn't work,
we'll try network two.
If that doesn't-- eventually,
I will find an ad.
The challenge is, if you don't
stack those networks correctly,
and if you don't change
the stack ranking based
on locale and user
and everything else,
you're likely not optimized.
And I don't mean change
these networks once a day-- I
mean, to really
get it optimized,
you're probably changing this
whole stack rank once an hour.
And that's simply impossible
for any developer to do.
So we've developed a
technology called Ad Network
Optimization-- it's available
to all of our AdMob publishers.
And what we do is
that we analyze
the performance of these
networks over time,
so that we can predict, for each
impression, which network will
perform best given
things like the region
of the user, the time
of day, the day of week.
And we believe that with
features like Ad Network
Optimization, we can
optimize mediation
as much as possible until the
industry eventually shifts
to things like ad exchanges
and real-time bidding,
sort of integrating
that single auction.
This is an example showing
how we found that right slot.
Lastly, I want to talk
about how we scale.
And at Google, we bring
you truly global demand.
Any AdMob customer has access
to millions of advertisers
through AdWords.
You also have access to the
DoubleClick ad exchange, which
brings millions more ads in
through 1,400 certified ad
networks in over 400 DSPs.
And all of these, as I
was hinting at earlier,
run in a single,
real-time auction.
And that demand flows
directly into AdMob,
you can use it in the mediation
ad network optimization stacks
that you saw behind me.
I'm incredibly
excited to announce
that large partners
around the world
are understanding what
we're building with AdMob,
and really latching
onto the demand
that we're able to provide with
our extremely high fill rates.
And as such, I
couldn't be happier
to announce that Etermax and
their hit game, Trivia Crack,
has, as of June 1,
I think, going live
exclusively with AdMob.
It's an incredible,
positive proof point
that the tools that
we're building in AdMob
work for all developers of
all scale around the world.
One of the other pieces that
most large developers ask
us about is reservations
or direct sales.
As you grow up, some
businesses end up
having their own
sales organization--
they want to be able
to sell their own ads.
Well, it often doesn't make up
the lion's share of revenue,
it is a nice way to
differentiate your brand.
So our team is working
incredibly hard
to bring AdMob reservations to
all of our AdMob publishers,
some of whom are running
a beta with us right now.
We're going to enable you to
run these campaigns, delivered
based on either clicks
or impression goals,
to paste the campaigns
using some of Google
and DoubleClick's
world class pacing
and throttling technology,
ultimately to empower
all of your sales teams.
We've got more to announce
on this later this year.
We're really, really excited
about how this is shaping up.
Google Web Designer
is a fantastic tool
that we brought into the display
family about three years ago.
This is an incredible
team who's worked
on things like Macromedia
Flash in the past,
and they have brought a
fully featured WYSIWYG HTML5
rich media editing tool
to the desktop, that
connects beautifully into AdMob
as well as our DoubleClick
products.
And what you see
here is an example
of how folks have used
Google Web Designer to create
a rich media HTML5
app install ad,
and one that could be served
directly from Google's
reservation system.
The last thing that we're going
to talk about is simplicity.
Integration becomes
absolutely critical,
and our launch of native
ads has been incredibly
successful with many publishers
and app developers adopting
this already.
In fact, you see a great
example behind me--
our friends at
Atari are utilizing
AdMob in Roller
Coaster Tycoon 4,
and they're showing off
these native ads there.
Native ads are
great for developers
with the sophistication to
take in these various bundles
of assets and lay
them out in ways
that make sense for their apps.
It truly makes these
ads experiences
integrative, native, and flow
within the rest of the app.
But it is a fair amount of work.
And this is what we're starting
to hear from some of you,
as we're rolling this out.
And so we've been
thinking about how
we can make this even easier.
So we're introducing Native Ads
Express, and this is in beta.
This is a pretty
cool feature, and you
see it animated behind me.
The idea here is
that we should be
able to create these
creatives on your behalf,
based on the uniqueness of your
app, the stylings of your app,
the colors, the font
choices, et cetera.
And we do this very
simply-- all you have to do
is give us a template.
Upload a CSS file,
and based on that,
we can render an entire
set of our demand
in ways that fit
within your app.
And the only thing
you need to do,
if you want to change the look
and feel of those native ads,
is send us a new CSS sheet.
And you see it basically
animating here behind me,
so you get a feel
for how easy that is.
Really proud of this.
So the growth of AdMob
interstitial impressions
over the last year or
so has been phenomenal.
It has roughly doubled.
We've seen more and more use
of interstitial impressions
on the network driving
more and more demand
to all of our partners.
And again, we
believe that this is
a great experience for users,
publishers, and advertisers
alike.
But ultimately, we want to make
sure it is as easy as possible
to integrate AdMob
into all of your apps,
so that even if you don't
want to monetize from day one,
you can monetize
three months later.
And this is why we're
announcing a new feature--
AdMob in the Android
Developer Studio.
So you'll be able to add AdMob
as an activity in your app,
just by making some simple
selections within Studio.
You can actually
define the type of ads
that you want to show in
your app, as you see here.
And then later, once you
have an AdMob account,
you can drop your AdMob
count ID into the dev studio.
And when your app is
published, you will show ads,
and you will make money.
It is really that simple.
Certainly you're going
to want to do more,
you're going to want
to customize this,
you're going to want to
optimize it over time,
but certainly think about taking
the initial steps to integrate
AdMob with all of your apps
before you launch them,
even if you're not thinking
about monetization today.
It's incredibly simple.
And for the game developers
in the audience--
I think you know this,
but as a quick reminder--
we're already integrated
within Unity and Coco's 2D,
so that's a great way to
take advantage of AdMob
from a game developer
perspective.
To summarize-- we are incredibly
committed to helping all of you
on Android and iOS not
just build the best apps
that you can, but build
businesses out of those apps
in ways that are scalable,
in ways that are global.
By taking advantage
of our tools,
you're going to be able to
build smart monetization
opportunities, new
business models that
will help you differentiate
and stand out from the crowd.
We will provide you
the tools to scale.
So if you start
with 100,000 users,
it will work great if you
grow to 20 million or 100
million users-- all of this
stuff will continue to scale.
And last, we're trying to
make it as easy as possible.
Because I've been in the
online advertising space
for probably the better
part of the last 15 years,
and this stuff is even
complicated to me.
You guys have to
focus on what you
do best, which is
designing and building
the very best mobile apps
and mobile games out there.
So we are working
our butts off to make
ad integration as simple and
painless as possible for all
of you.
With that, I'd like to thank
you guys so much for your time
and enjoy the rest of I/O.